our thoughts with those essential
workers that are putting the work in
right now even though overwhelmed now we
have an update a sad update on the case
of gabby petito who vanished while on a
cross-country road trip with her fiance
an autopsy confirmed that yesterday the
body that was found in wyoming on sunday
is gabby petitto jerica duncan is at the
search site in venice florida where law
enforcement's are looking for her fiance
brian laundry jerika what else did the
autopsy show
you know that autopsy nate showed that
the preliminary determination cause of
death was homicide but the autopsy did
not give details as to how she was
killed and we don't expect to get that
full report possibly for up to another
two weeks now where we are standing
again the carlton reserve in venice as
you mentioned is where the search
efforts will resume for brian laundry
the 23 year old returned home to florida
without potito on september 1st
laundry's parents say he left home a
week ago they reported him missing to
authorities on friday investigators
restarted their search through the 24
acres of land here it is very swampy
there are alligators snakes in the
reserve just to give you an idea of what
these investigators are dealing with in
this search now
back here live overnight there were
rumors
that investigators did have brian
laundry in custody but authorities
quickly shut that down but of course
things could change at any moment in
cases like this of course we will
continue to keep you updated with any
new information
jerica thank you now you can see more of
jerica's coverage of the gabby potato
case this saturday night on 48 hours